tomorrow, Joe Biden will be president of the
United States.
We're sort of closing the book on the Trump
presidency today in a few different ways.
And one such way is looking at approval rating.
Donald Trump is leaving the White House with
the lowest job approval of his presidency,
which is 29 percent.
And yet it still seems so high.
How could nearly a third of the people in
this country, less than a third, but nearly
a third of the people in this country think
he's doing a good job?
Still, he's been doing nothing for months
other than inciting that riotous insurrection
on January 6th.
And it is true that Trump voters have grown
more critical of Trump in his post-election
conduct.
The share of Trump supporters who describe
his conduct as poor has doubled over the last
two months from 10 percent to 20 percent.
A significant majority of Americans don't
want Trump Trump to remain a major political
figure after he leaves office.
About two thirds say Trump should be should
evaporate as a as a primary political figure
of the United States.
Joe Biden is entering with 64 percent positive
opinion, which is great only in the sense
that it bodes well and sets Biden up well
for the crucial start of his presidency, where
we need everybody on the same page in order
to finally get this pandemic under control,
scale up vaccination and do the things that
have to be done.
So those are all good signs.
But in term of the terms of the January 6th
Trump riots, three quarters of the public
say that Trump bears at least some responsibility
for the violence and destruction committed
by some of his supporters.
52 percent say Trump bears a lot of responsibility,
but we still have twenty four percent.
Nearly a quarter of this country says Trump
has zero responsibility for what took place.
That's extraordinarily weaponized disinformation.
And then maybe most disturbing, a majority
of Republicans still think that Donald Trump
actually won the election.
Understand that 64 percent of Republican voters
still believe as of a few days ago when this
survey was done, that it is actually Donald
Trump who won the election.
Two thirds of Republicans believe the guy
who's being sworn in tomorrow did not really
win.
And by the way, six percent of Democrats also
believe Trump won.
I'd be interested in talking to some of those
folks that that's that's quite a bit that's
just as depressing, quite frankly.
Meanwhile, this is not the only data point
from Pew in the Gallup presidential approval
tracking poll.
Trump also falling there to a presidency low
of 34 percent approval.
And I have the same reaction to both the 29
percent and 34 percent approval numbers, 29
percent and 34 percent approval for Trump
are way too high.
Those numbers tell us that something is very
wrong with the country, as if we didn't already
know.
But it confirms it.
Approval should be zero if only all of this
had been completely predictable when Donald
Trump ran for president back in 2015.
Oh, wait a second.
It was completely predictable and we were
predicting that it would be this bad.
So there will be time for postmortems, but
it's still shocking and saddening that there
are people who thought Hillary would be the
same as Trump or Hillary would be as bad as
Trump, or it would make no difference to to
the day to day, day to day lives of Americans,
whether it's Trump or Hillary.
Some people over the last year were saying
similar things about Joe Biden.
Joe Biden would be as bad as Trump.
I hope no one is listening to those people
anymore because they've given up their right
to be listened to.
I'm not saying they shouldn't be allowed to
speak.
I'm not violating anyone's suggesting anyone's
First Amendment rights be violated.
I'm just saying at this point, we have enough
evidence to realize we shouldn't be listening
to those people.
By the way, there are also people who went
from voting for Bernie to voting for Trump
that also knowing everything we know now is
extraordinarily disturbing.
It was disturbing back in 2016.
It's even more disturbing now because everything
has been so utterly predictable and yet some
people are still acting surprised.
So good news.
Trump's going out with the lowest approval
rating of his presidency.
Bad news, nearly a third of the country, nearly
a third of the country, meaning about 70 million
people still support the absolutely.
I'm sorry, no doubt 90 something million people.
My math was wrong.
Something around 90 million people still think
Trump is doing a good job, and that's going
to be something we'll have to deal with for
much, much more time than Trump is in office,
which is fortunately just a few more hours.
T